thousands of people plan to gather in
Cleveland tomorrow to mark the 50th
anniversary of a fire that sparked a
nationwide environmental movement Jeff
Glor the new co-host of CBS this morning
Saturday I can't say the way I love
saying it went back to Ohio to examine
what happened after the heavily polluted
Cuyahoga River started burning well
different now than 1969 it's gorgeous
Jen dreicer of Cleveland Metroparks took
us for a tour of the current day
Cuyahoga we are in the federal
navigations ship channel of the Cuyahoga
River and we are nearing the the mouth
of the river where this weekend people
are celebrating the last time the river
burned exactly 50 years ago June 22nd
1969 why because it hasn't happened
since bill Skowronski was just a kid out
of college then a member of the
fledgling Ohio Environmental Protection
Agency you could probably name just
about any liquid chemical and it was
being dumped in the river so you'd have
oil gasoline kerosene acids caustic
materials for more than a hundred years
these waterways were waste receptacles
the churna factories won Wars and
propelled an American Century but the
bills came too in the late 60s and early
70s after an embarrassing series of
river fires across the Rust Belt the
kaga River leading to the passage of the
Clean Water Act gave us a level playing
field across the country and guess who
was here live it in color Jeff Glor Jeff
walk sitting room people I'm Jeff I'd
like to know that people are so glad to
see you welcome it's good to be here
yeah we're really glad you're here let's
talk about your story in the fire in
particular how did it change history
right so this the fire ended up leading
to the National Environmental Policy Act
which is the first sort of muscular
National Environmental Law which
happened after this fire and other River
fires across the Rust Belt and back then
it wasn't a partisan issue right the the
law was signed by Richard Nixon
everybody rally behind it it has since
become a partisan issue what the EPA
does and some of these issues we'll talk
more about that this morning about
Cleveland what's happened there and
across the Rust Belt in
remember has it you have a video of a
guy or you met a guy who is fishing in
the river and eating fish out of that
river that happening right so as of
March of this year you are allowed to I
mean you could have always eaten the
fish at your own risk
it wasn't March of this year the Ohio
EPA says you can eat the fish in the
river so you want to catch that walleye
and we're like this weekend go ahead
that's an amazing transformation I love
it yeah all right Jeff goron the fire a
little bit later on on the Cayuga River
and its transformation that's tomorrow
on CBS this morning
your turn Anthony was saying it's a
first Saturday you've had often what a
gazillion seven years or your sleep yes
enjoy your first day and the new job
right sure